Sollten dumme Menschen sterben?
Ihr dachtet doch nicht,
das ist Clickbait, oder?
* Titelmusik *
Vor kurzem habe ich ein Video
zur Tide Pod-Challenge hochgeladen.
In den Kommentaren tauchen immer
wieder zwei Begriffe auf, nämlich:
Früher starben schwache Menschen,
indem sie von Säbelzahntigern
gefressen wurden.
Heute sterben dumme Jugendliche,
indem sie Waschmittel essen.
Natürliche Selektion.
Muss man dumme Menschen schützen,
indem man ihnen sagt,
bleibt sicher
und esst kein Waschmittel?
Oder sollte man einfach
den Darwinismus walten lassen?
Aaah, ich verlier die Geduld.
Ich wünsche mir,
dass der Darwinismus voll zuhaut.
Die Idee wird auf die Spitze
getrieben bei den sog.Darwin-Awards.
Das sind satirische Awards.
Sie zeichnen Menschen aus,
die sich versehentlich selbst töten,
tödlich verunfallen
oder selbst unfruchtbar machen
und ein besonderes Maß
an Dummheit zeigen.
Dahinter steht der Gedanke, dass
ein lebensuntüchtiges Individuum
seiner Art einen Gefallen tut,
wenn es die Verbreitung
des eigenen Erbguts verhindert.
People such as these
deserve our honor and respect
for their sacrifice
to improve the next generation
of the human species.
Sprich, je mehr dumme
Menschen sterben, desto weniger
dummes Erbgut und desto schlauer
die künftigen Generationen
der menschlichen Spezies.
Falls ihr die Darwin-Awards
noch nicht kennt,
könnt ihr euch ein Bild davon
machen, Link in der Beschreibung.
Ich persönlich finde die Awards
so ziemlich genau 0 % witzig.
Das Grausame an einem Tod
ist nicht nur der Tod an sich,
sondern vor allem
das Leid der Hinterbliebenen.
Ich finde die Awards geschmacklos,
aber das ist meine Meinung,
die hier nichts zur Sache tut.
Denn über Humor kann man sich
bekanntlich nicht streiten.
Zumindest sollte man das nicht.
Aber wenn es schon schwarzer Humor
ist, würde ich wenigstens erwarten,
dass die Wissenschaft
dahinter stimmt.
Das tut sie leider
vorne und hinten nicht.
Umso mehr irritiert es mich,
dass die Darwin-Awards
v.a.in gebildeteren,
akademischen Kreisen beliebt sind.
Immerhin beruht der Witz
auf der wissenschaftlichen Basis
der Evolutionstheorie,
was ein gewisses Maß
an Bildung voraussetzt.
Die Gründerin der Darwin-Awards
ist Molekularbiologin
und Berkeley-Absolventin.
Deswegen möchte ich heute
nicht auf ethischer Ebene rumheulen,
warum ich die Awards
geschmacklos finde,
sondern das Ganze
rein wissenschaftlich angehen.
Hier also vier Gründe,
warum die Darwin-Awards
wissenschaftlicher Bullshit sind.
Ist Dummheit überhaupt
genetisch bedingt oder nicht?
Nach über 100 Jahren Forschung
weiß man heute nur,
dass Intelligenz durchaus eine
starke genetische Komponente hat.
Aber auch, dass Umwelteinflüsse
eine Rolle spielen.
Kurz gesagt, auf die Frage, ob
Intelligenz genetisch bedingt ist,
gibt es bis heute keine
eindeutigen und einfachen Antworten.
Falls ihr euch
für das Thema interessiert,
verlinke ich euch ein paar
Artikel in der Beschreibung.
Trotzdem kann man
logisch argumentieren:
In diesem Fall macht das Konzept
der Awards keinen Sinn.
Ja, nur dann würde man
auch dumm geboren werden,
genauso wie man mit einer
gewissen Hautfarbe geboren wird,
und es wäre ähnlich sinnlos,
sich über etwas lustig zu machen,
wofür ein Mensch gar nichts kann.
Ich mach zu viele air quotes heute.
Wenn ich jetzt sterbe, sterben
mit mir nicht alle meine Gene.
Z.B.hab ich einen Bruder,
der ein potentielles
Dummheitsgen weitervererben könnte.
Außerdem beruht das Ganze
auf einem weitverbreiteten Irrtum,
der mit dem Survival
of the Fittest... schon wieder...
Survival
of the Fittest zusammenhängt.
Bei der Evolution
und der natürlichen Selektion
geht es nicht primär ums Überleben,
sondern vielmehr um Reproduktion,
also um den Fortbestand der Art.
Genau genommen
ist die reine Reproduktion
nicht allein ausschlaggebend.
Wenn wir etwa ein Rudeltier nehmen,
das sein Rudel beschützt,
sich selbst aber nicht fortpflanzt,
hat das trotzdem für die ganze Art
einen evolutionären Vorteil.
Aber es macht keinen Sinn,
einen erwachsenen Mann,
der zwei Kinder hat
und auf saudumme Art stirbt,
mit einem Darwin-Award
auszuzeichnen,
weil er sich
schon fortgepflanzt hat.
Er hat sich damit ein bisschen
zu spät aus dem Gen-Pool entfernt.
Interessanterweise
wird der Darwin-Award
nicht an Kinder
und Jugendliche verliehen.
Gibt es dafür
einen wissenschaftlichen Grund?
Keiner, der mir einleuchten würde,
denn es würde viel Sinn machen,
den Award an Kinder
und Jugendliche zu verleihen,
weil die sich in der Regel
noch nicht fort gepflanzt haben.
Oder ist es
eine ethische Entscheidung,
weil man keine Witze
über verstorbene Kinder
und Jugendliche macht,
das geht zu weit.
Witze über verstorbene Erwachsene?
Klar, ha ha.
Aber Witze
über Kinder und Jugendliche?
Wir sind doch keine Monster.
Falls das der Grund sein sollte,
find ich das nicht weit gedacht.
Denn unter den Hinterbliebenen
der Verstorbenen,
über die man sich lustig macht,
befinden sich sicher
auch Kinder und Jugendliche,
die schon genug unter dem Tod
an sich leiden und jetzt auch noch
drunter leiden müssen,
dass sich fremde Menschen
nicht nur über den Tod, sondern
auch die Dummheit lustig machen.
Ich wollte nicht moralisch werden,
bleiben wir bei der Wissenschaft.
Der Begriff natürliche Selektion
klingt nach einer aktiven Selektion.
Als würde die Evolution
einen Plan verfolgen,
eine systematische Verbesserung.
Die Wahrheit ist, die Evolution
hat keinen aktiven Plan
wie irgend ein Gott,
sondern ist völlig random.
Es geht hier nicht
um systematische Verbesserung.
Es geht nicht darum,
dass Spezies immer stärker, größer,
schneller oder intelligenter werden.
Sonst gäbe es
nicht die Artenvielfalt,
die wir auf dem Planeten
beobachten können.
Spezies verbessern sich nicht,
sie passen sich
immer besser an ihre Umwelt an.
Die Umwelt ist gleichzeitig
auch ein Teil der Evolution
und entwickelt sich
und passt sich an.
Nehmen wir den Kiwi,
den Nationalvogel Neuseelands.
Vergleicht man den Kiwi
mit anderen Vögeln dieses Planeten,
bekommt man leicht den Eindruck,
dass der Kiwi anderen Vögeln
objektiv unterlegen ist.
Er kann nicht fliegen,
nicht schnell laufen,
ist nicht groß genug, um sich
gegen Raubtiere zu verteidigen
und nicht klein genug,
um sich leicht zu verstecken.
Tatsächlich wären die Kiwis
heute längst ausgestorben,
seit die Menschen
Marder, Opossums und Ähnliches
nach Neuseeland eingeschleppt haben.
Kiwis sind heute nur überlebensfähig
dank Bemühungen der Naturschützer.
Trotzdem hat die Evolution
in Neuseeland den Kiwi
genau so hervorgebracht.
Das, Freunde der Sonne, ist ein
Survivor und einer of the Fittest.
Der Kiwi war perfekt
an seine Umgebung angepasst.
Bis der Mensch kam
und ein paar Marder ausgesetzt hat.
Genauso ist der Homo Sapiens
Tieren in vielen Dingen unterlegen.
Z.B.würde ein Menschenbaby
alleine sofort sterben.
Während Schildkrötenbabys schlüpfen,
ins Meer laufen
und einfach anfangen zu schwimmen.
Objektiv
und wissenschaftlich korrekt gesehen
gibt es keine guten
und schlechten oder besseren Gene.
Man kann nur gut oder schlecht
an seine Umgebung angepasst sein.
Es ist nicht nur
wissenschaftlich falsch,
sondern kann auch ethisch
grenzwertig gefährlich werden,
wenn man evolutionstechnisch
hierarchisch denkt
in gut und schlecht.
Im Extremfall kommen Auswüchse
wie die Idee von der Herrenrasse
dabei raus und...
ok, jetzt bin ich
ethisch sehr weit abgeschweift.
Zurück zur Wissenschaft.
Nehmen wir an,
Intelligenz ist genetisch bedingt.
Dann gibt es doch bei aller Liebe
einige andere
genetisch bedingte Eigenschaften,
die bei der Fortpflanzung von
Vorteil sind, sind wir mal ehrlich.
Ohnehin streiten sich Experten
darüber, ob die Evolution derzeit
beim Menschen
überhaupt noch so stattfindet
oder wie sie in modernen Zeiten
zu bewerten ist.
Das Kiwi-Beispiel
ist nur eines von vielen dafür,
wie der Mensch
seine Umgebung rasant verändert,
viel schneller
als die Evolution nachziehen kann.
Intelligenz ist für Menschen in
ihrer Umgebung sicher ein Vorteil.
Phänomene
wie der Flynn-Effekt zeigen,
dass sich Menschen auch hier
durchaus an ihre Umgebung anpassen.
Falls ihr nicht wisst,
was der Flynn-Effekt ist:
sehr interessantes Video.
Intelligenz korreliert heutzutage
mit Sachen wie Einkommen
oder Lebensstandard.
Aber pflanzen sich
reiche Akademiker mehr fort?
Eher nicht, würde ich sagen.
Mir fällt jetzt erst auf,
dass man aus genau diesem Grund
argumentieren könnte,
dass man die Darwin-Awards braucht.
Die Menschheit verdummt, Intelligenz
ist kein evolutionärer Vorteil mehr.
Deswegen ist es
ein Grund zum Feiern,
wenn sich
ein dummer Mensch umbringt.
Tja, das kann man so sehen,
aber dann darf man das Ganze
nicht Darwin-Awards nennen,
denn mit Charles Darwin
hat es nichts mehr zu tun,
sondern muss es dann nennen:
Jetzt mal im Ernst,
so Darwinismus-Kommentare
und selbst die Darwin-Awards
sind ein Witz.
Sie sind als Witz gedacht,
ich find sie nicht witzig,
aber das tut nichts zur Sache.
Ich find auch
Big Bang Theory nicht witzig.
Es geht mir wirklich
nicht um eine Humordebatte.
Gerade unter 'nem Video
über die Tide Pod-Challenge,
wo zum Glück
noch keiner gestorben ist,
finde ich es weniger problematisch.
Mir geht's darum,
dass Leute aufgeklärt sind.
Wenn sie Witze machen wie:
So funktioniert Evolution nun mal,
möchte ich,
dass sie wenigstens wissen,
dass Evolution
so nun mal nicht funktioniert.
Egal, wie Intelligenz
tatsächlich genetisch bedingt ist:
Dummheit hat am Ende
sehr viel mit Bildung zu tun.
Deswegen teilt dieses Video.
Wenn ihr es teilt, macht es
die Menschheit etwas schlauer.
Ich bin schamlos, bleibt sicher,
Freunde der Sonne. Wir sehen uns.
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk (2018)
Wisst ihr, was ich auch noch dachte
bei der Tide Pod-Challenge?
So dumm die auch ist oder war,
als ich 12, 13 war,
hab ich viele
sehr dumme Sachen gemacht.
Ich bin
in 'ner Kleinstadt aufgewachsen
und bei uns auf dem Dorf haben
viele mit 13 angefangen zu saufen.
Wenn mein Alkoholabbauenzym
nicht mutiert wäre,
hätte ich wahrscheinlich mitgemacht.
Das ist im Zweifel gefährlicher
als Waschmittel zu essen.
Deswegen mal unter uns:
Was habt ihr früher Dummes gemacht
und habt ihr schon mal durch
Dummheit euer Leben gefährdet?
Schreibt es in die Kommentare, ich
werde euch dafür nicht verurteilen.